bonjour Grégoire Renault bonjour Nicolas
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
quelle place à El Hermann Titon ici à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est toutes
les activités françaises sont ici à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines absolument sur
le plateau de 50 ans en Yvelines où on
est depuis 30 ans maintenant en fait
notre 30e anniversaire ici sur place
sachant que la mandaton France a 60 ans
et donc on a à peu près 250
collaborateurs sur différents bâtiments
donc ici à Trappes où on est à peu près
200 et on a une trentaine de
collaborateurs sur notre entrepôt
logistique à Coignières toujours sur le
sur Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et alors
vous c'est de l'industrie vraiment de
précision parce que finalement vous êtes
sur des
outils des instruments critiques de
secteurs industriels oui alors tout à
fait déjà quand on dit industriel il
faut bien comprendre l'industrie au sens
large c'est-à-dire qu'on a des donneurs
d'ordre et des partenaires commerciaux
dans l'automobile dans l'aéronautique le
ferroviaire le naval etc
ce qui fait que on va pouvoir livrer des
pièces à du Dassault à des
constellations de satellites à des
constructeurs automobiles que vous
connaissez aussi bien que moi donc c'est
très varié et on est sur des exigences
spécifiques assez élevées que ce soit
sur le type de matériaux que l'on
utilise sur des résistances en
mécaniques en température en acoustique
etc on le voit sur ces images c'est
vraiment des petits composants alors non
pas électroniques mais des composants en
plastique qui permettent de maintenir
des câbles c'est ça alors tout à fait
nous ce sont des pièces plastiques qui
vont permettre de fixer de protéger
d'identifier les fils électriques les
câbles donc les faisceaux mais également
des tubulures dans lesquels passent des
fluides et en fait les pièces plastiques
peuvent avoir différentes tailles ça
peut être des colliers de serrage de une
dizaine de centimètres jusqu'à des
grandes goulottes qui vont porter des
faisceaux électriques et qui peuvent
mesurer jusqu'à un mètre et demi de
mètres alors avant de rentrer dans les
détails on va revenir tout de suite sur
cette inauguration le 12 mai dernier à
ce moment là Andrew Leyland le président
de larmon title du groupe et l'armée
title était venu ici pour inaugurer les
machines qu'on voit derrière nous on va
l'écouter d'abord et puis après on
rentrera dans les détails on les coupe
tout de suite
[Musique]
en France représente une part importante
du groupe et Norman title dans le monde
la France a de vrais atouts dans
différentes industries mondiales
[Musique]
ce centre de R&D est situé dans cette
zone d'innovation et de technologie
nous pouvons donc travailler étroitement
avec ses clients
[Applaudissements]
dans le monde
au début de la pandémie nous avons
décidé que l'élément le plus important
pour elermann title et de se focaliser
sur l'innovation et maintenant cet
investissement montre que nous
continuons à investir et à supporter
l'innovation et la technologie pour la
France et pour les sites en Europe et
dont le monde
cet investissement nous assure la
possibilité de fournir des solutions
innovantes
et nouvelle pour rester au dessus des
autres entreprises
une des spécificités c'est LA CHAMBRE
BLANCHE des environnements sains dans
laquelle nous pouvons développer des
solutions
c'est le cas pour l'industrie médicale
et agroalimentaire où vous avez besoin
de haut niveau de qualité
ce qui va contribuer au succès du groupe
dans le monde entier
[Musique]
donc voilà on vient d'entendre Andrew
les Landes donc le président du
groupe Titon voilà il était venu pour le
texte Center il a fait le déplacement
c'est que c'est très important quand
même pour lrman Dayton le texte Center
alors oui tout à fait ce centre tout
nouveau de recherche et de développement
vous voyez c'est très propre parce que
on a trois presses complètement
nouvelles après c'est injecter du
plastique de 60 tonnes 100 tonnes et 200
tonnes où on va pouvoir travailler en
environnement sale grise voire même sale
blanche donc on est sur des exigences en
termes de particules et de pollution
assez élevée et ce texte enter va
pouvoir nous aider à travailler en
innovation pour mieux servir encore nos
clients par rapport à des besoins qu'ils
ont déjà exprimés et des besoins qui
n'ont pas encore exprimé et on va aller
leur faire comprendre de façon à se
différencier par rapport à la
concurrence et justement garder notre
activité ici sur 50 ans en Yvelines
alors par rapport à ce texte Center
quels sont les objectifs à la fois
stratégiques et technologiques ok alors
en lien avec le texte Center notre
ambition c'est de développer des
nouvelles pièces
notre première objectif donc ça va nous
permettre de tester des nouveaux design
des nouveaux moules des nouvelles
matières ça c'est vraiment très
important on va être encore plus
respectueux de l'environnement donc des
nouvelles matières
des nouveaux processus on travaille sur
les réglages que après on va pouvoir
dupliquer à notre
outil industriel à notre centre de
production ce sont des presses
électriques donc pas hydrauliques donc
c'est mieux pour l'environnement et
effectivement en premier lieu on va
pouvoir utiliser une partie de nos
rebroyés qui viennent de la production
donc ce sont de la matière plastique qui
n'a pas été utilisée ou qui a été
utilisé mais qu'on peut réutiliser une
nouvelle fois et on va pouvoir faire des
des essais grâce à ses presses là pour
réutiliser cela après en production et
être moins consommateur de matière et
donc d'énergie alors le texte Center
c'est finalement un nouvel outil dans la
R&D de l'armagne title la R&D est déjà
présente avant ce texte enter alors oui
et c'est un de nos avantages très fort
parce que France nous avons un bureau de
recherche et de développement de design
on a recruté l'année dernière et on
prévoit de recruter encore l'année
prochaine pour développer nos
compétences en matière de développement
avec beaucoup de recherches associées et
en lien avec l'innovation qui vient de
des piliers dans le groupe et hormone
tyton et en quoi consiste les activités
de R&D dans ce type d'activité c'est
quoi c'est la conception des pièces
alors ça va être la conception des
pièces ça va être aussi l'optimisation
du design des moules ça va être
également l'utilisation des de matières
plastiques à recycler ça va être aussi
voir dans quelle mesure des nouvelles
matières
polyamides entre autres mais pas que
peuvent être incorporés dans les
produits que l'on propose à nos donneurs
d'ordre donc voilà c'est un petit peu
tout ça que le texte enter va nous
permettre de faire alors on comprend
bien donc c'est presque permettent
d'améliorer ce que vous faisiez déjà
avant
tout à fait ça va nous permettre
d'améliorer significativement ce que
l'on faisait avant mais également
d'adresser de nouveaux marchés comme je
décrivais précédemment on va pouvoir
travailler en environnement sale grise
salle blanche et donc aujourd'hui on
adresse de nouveaux marchés médical
paramédicales l'agroalimentaire les
énergies renouvelables les champs
d'éoliennes les champs de panneaux
solaires notamment alors justement on va
aller rejoindre Hardy Da Costa qui est
chef d'équipe de production et découvrir
justement les machines qui fonctionnent
actuellement à côté de ces trois presses
derrière nous parfait merci